Don't believe the newspaper headlines that
are saying,
‘The rich are going to make out like bandits
with this tax legislation.’ Not true at all.
This is going to make the tax code more progressive,
which is not a good thing from my point of
view.
Hi, this is Nick Gillespie for Reason.
Today we're talking with Chris Edwards.
He's the Director of Tax Policy at the Cato
Institute
and we're talking about Republican tax reform
and the implications for the economy
and what it means for libertarians.
Chris, thanks for talking to us.
Thanks a lot for having me, Nick.
Give us your general score card. Is this good?
Is it bad? Is it somewhere in between?
The main driver here is the corporate tax
reforms.
The United States has the highest corporate
tax rate in the world.
The Republicans would slash the corporate
tax rate down pretty dramatically
down to 20% at the federal level.
And that's from 35%?
From 35 down to 20%.
That sounds pretty low, but actually the global
average rate is only 24% today.
If you think about the United States, we've
got our federal rate,
but we've got state corporate taxes on top
up to about 10% or more.
Even with the Republican cuts, we'd only just
barely start getting competitive globally.
That's the corporate stuff.
Before we get to the individual side, with
the corporate stuff,
one of the things that opponents of tax reform
say is,
‘So, corporations make a huge amount of
money. They're solelists literally and figuratively.’
Why are we cutting taxes on corporations and
what is the thinking behind that?
Why is that a good thing?
You'll hear critics say, ‘American corporations
are usually profitable today.
A lot of them are sitting on a big pile of
cash. Why do they need tax cuts?’
The reason is because corporations are forward
looking.
They think about building a new factory here
versus in Mexico or China,
and they look at that stream of future profits
and they look at how much the government tax
grab on that will be.
They might be sitting on cash now, but the
reason they're not investing it
is because the U.S. corporate tax rate is
so high.
You cut the corporate tax rate, corporations
at the margin,
there would be more factories,
more hiring will make more sense in the United
States versus our competitors.
They will invest more in the long run, and
they'll build more factories.
You build more factories, you got to hire
more workers,
the demand for U.S. workers will go up and
then wages will rise.
This sounds like Trump's, but this is Trump's
nightmare,
because then suddenly people from Mexico are
going to start coming back to the United States
instead of leaving, which is what's happening.
You know the demand for labor will go up a
lot.
The reality, Nick, is that even though the
U.S. unemployment rate is pretty low now,
our participation rate in the labor force
has been falling,
especially for middle-aged men for a number
of decades now.
We want to get a lot of those folks off the
sidelines back in the workforce.
I think the corporate tax cut really goes
to that issue.
There's also a shift, and I guess this affects
both the corporate as well as the individual
rates.
The U.S. currently taxes on a global basis.
Both plans would shift into a territorial
basis.
What's the difference and why is that important?
Right now, U.S. corporations,
you think about a big corporation like General
Motors or DuPont or Intel,
they have subsidiaries in dozens and dozens
of countries around the world.
The United States today says, ‘We're going
to tax you on your global operations.’
Think about this.
DuPont, let's say they have a subsidiary in
Brazil
making some chemical product to supply the
Brazilian market.
The U.S. government taxes those profits right
now.
But you think about a German chemical company
with a subsidiary in Brazil serving the Brazilian
market,
the German government at home doesn't really
care what the subsidiary does,
and so it's more competitive than the U.S.
subsidiary.
How does that affect us?
We want our foreign subsidiaries to be competitive
because they expand their sales and global
markets.
The profits pour back into the United States
and that tends to suck exports out of the
United States.
When our corporations do well abroad,
they take a lot of imported, intermediate
goods from their U.S. production.
We want our multinationals to do well, it
means they'll invest here,
more global headquarters of companies will
locate here,
and their foreign subsidiaries will do well,
which is good for our workers in our economy.
As you know, there's been this drain over
the last few decades
on multinationals moving their headquarters
out of the United States,
because it's a punishing place to locate the
headquarters of multinationals.
Republicans moved to what's called a territorial
system,
so that'll draw multinational headquarters
back to the United States.
The corporate side, or the business side of
this seems pretty good,
and from a libertarian, from a free market
angle, there's not that much to complain about
other than rates could always be lower.
The individual side is more of a shit show,
right?
Absolutely. It's basically reassembling deck
chairs on a really messy and horribly complex
system.
There is a little bit of simplification.
Republicans double the standard deduction,
so that means more people will be taking the
standard deduction,
less people taking itemized deductions like
the mortgage interest deduction.
That's good. It's a bit of a simplification.
There's a little bit of rate cut in.
I think that the joint committee on taxation,
the official scoring body,
found that there would be a better average
of about a two percent marginal rate cut on
the individual side,
sort of on average.
That's good, but there will be a lot of new
complexity,
Republicans will cut the tax rate on so-called
pass-through or small businesses a little
bit,
but the rules will be very complicated.
If you're a law firm, you don't get the rate
cut,
but if you're a small manufacturing firm,
you do get the rate cut,
there will be a lot of lobbying and fighting
over those sorts of breaks.
Why is it good to get people out of itemizing
deductions?
You said by increasing a standard deduction.
Why is itemization bad?
I think it treats people unfairly.
Right now, renters don't get the special break
from the government,
but homeowners do get the special break from
the government.
It's the same as other itemized deductions.
Why should the government be playing favorites,
giving special breaks for some Americans and
not others?
I think we ought to have low rates and equal
treatment across the board.
You pay a certain flat percentage on what
you earn, although,
I would have a large deduction at the bottom,
because there's no point taxing people who
are below the poverty level,
because they get the government benefits anyways,
so have a big giant exemption and then tax
everyone a flat rate across the board equally.
We're in a situation where there might even
be a majority of Americans
living in households that pay no federal income
tax.
On a certain level, that seems great.
You're poor, you shouldn't be paying it.
When you're talking about half of the population,
why does it present a problem to take everybody
off the tax rolls?
One of the reasons why you want to go to a
flat tax where everyone pays an equal amount
is then everyone feels the pain of big government.
Taxes are price of government, you want people
to feel the price,
and so that if they feel the full price of
government it limits the demand for big government.
That's a good thing.
You're right.
About 45% of U.S. households now pay absolutely
no federal income tax unfortunately.
The tax code is extremely progressive, to
use the liberal word for that.
I use the word graduated, meaning people at
the top pay this huge bulk of taxes.
As you know, some of these numbers,
the top one percent of highest earners pay
40% of all federal income taxes.
It's really incredible,
and that to share the burden paid by the top
group has gone up and up and up,
which means that the share paid by everyone
else,
by most voters has gone down, so they're demanding
more government.
That's not a good thing.
Here's a startling statistic.
The United States has the most progressive
or graduated income tax code
of all the OECD industrial countries.
The most progressive of all. It's remarkable,
and this is America.
That means that it goes from relatively poor
people pay little or no taxes
and the wealthier you are, the more highly
taxes you are.
Don't believe the newspaper headlines that
are saying,
‘The rich are going to make out like bandits
with this tax legislation.’ Not true at
all.
This is going to make the tax code more progressive,
which is not a good thing from my point of
view.
The other thing is that the overall level
of revenue that's generated ...
For most of 21st century, we've been pulling
in government revenue from all sources,
about 70% of GDP, right around there.
There were some declines during the recession
and whatnot.
Will this tax reform increase that amount,
and if it does,
is that a good thing from a libertarian market
point of view?
Do we want the government to be actually taking
more income out of our pockets?
The Republicans have set aside a trillion
and a half dollars over 10 years for this
tax cut,
and that's scored in static basis.
Some of the business reforms will increase.
GDP will move the economy upwards, so that'll
cause a reflow of revenue to the government.
However, it's still going to be a revenue
loser for the government.
This will be a net tax cut overall. The reason
is, as we were just discussing, a lot of the
individual tax changes don't do anything for
economic growth, so they're just a pure revenue
loss to the government. Those sorts of tax
cuts, I could take it or leave it. If you
believe in starve the beast, then yeah, let
people keep more of their money. For me, I
think if we're going to cut taxes, we ought
to cut taxes in a way that makes the overall
economy grow more strongly.
Let's talk a little bit about starve the beast,
which is the idea that if you reduce the amount
of money that government can raise it will
spend less. That pretty clearly is a wrong
theory because we've been borrowing and borrowing
more and more money, and nobody did that more
than George W. Bush, and Barack Obama followed
in his footsteps of putting more and more
on a national credit card. Is there any connection,
because this is what Republican proponents
of tax reform say, ‘We're going to get the
government, we're going to drop taxes and
the drag in the economy, and then we're going
to get spend in cuts.’ Is there any reason
to believe that, or what are the steps that
lead from tax reform to spending cuts down
the road?
Let me start at the state government level.
State governments are required to balance
their budgets every year. Starve the beast
does probably work, because a governor cuts
taxes, then it really forces the legislature
down the road to cut the spending. U.S. federal
government, of course, can spend as much as
it wants, so starve the beast doesn't seem
to work anymore. I think a few decades back,
starve the beast did work because politicians
were scared of big deficits. You saw during
the '80s, Reagan cuts taxes and then there
was a big movement with various budget reform
plans to try to restrain spending. That is
no longer the case, and the reason is because
we have global capital markets. The U.S. government
can borrow as much as it wants and it doesn't
push up interest rates. It doesn't push up
people mortgage rates. It doesn't cause any
pain for politicians.
Why should we worry about deficits? This is
something, when Republicans are in power and
they're running up deficits, Democrats are
like, ‘We need fiscal sanity.’ When Democrats
are in power, the Republicans suddenly become
deficit hawks and then that disappears very
quickly. Why is mounting national debt a problem
if the U.S. can keep borrowing money essentially
for free?
A couple reasons. One is most economists think
that some big financial or economic crash
will come down the road as our debt keeps
piling up over the decades. The second reason
is just the ethics of it. Borrowing now deficit's
debt, pushes costs to the future. You can
see that from a libertarian perspective very
simply. Right now, if the government has a
big spending program, it goes out and borrows
10 billion dollars for a spending program,
no one is hurt in the short run. People will
get the spending benefit, the creditors will
lend more money to the government. They don't
mind because they're doing it voluntarily,
so no one seems to lose. No one does now.
In the future, we got to pay back the debt,
the government's got to go out and use its
coercion to raise the taxes. From a libertarian
perspective, you can see the pain is moved
to the future when the government borrows
more now, and that's unethical, I think.
Is there some event horizon where we're actually
going to cut year over year spending, or is
this just kind of smoke and mirrors? Back
in the early '90s, George H. W. Bush pushed
through a tax plan, which was wildly unpopular.
He had made a ‘no new taxes’ pledge. All
the Republicans, all conservatives, all libertarians
said he was a sucker because he made the rookie
mistake of raising taxes now in the name of
spending cuts down the road and the spending
cuts never come. Now we're in a world where
we're doing tax cuts with spending cuts promised.
Are we just these big suckers?
Perhaps there's no relationship between taxes
and spending at all. At the federal level,
politicians like to cut taxes, they like to
increase spending. Maybe there's no relationship.
I'll give you one way that the Republican
tax cuts, if they go through in the next couple
weeks may be positive. That is, it does take
the whole tax reform issue off the plate of
the Republican politicians for a while. For
many years, Republican politicians, they can
prove their conservative bonafides by claiming
they're for big tax reform, and it's always
a crowd pleaser with Republican voters.
But they don't actually have to do it?
You're right. They keep saying, ‘We're going
to do tax reform down the road.’ This sort
of does take it off the agenda, I think, for
a while. A lot of this is going to depend
on what the Trump administration does. Trump
has a very good budget director, as you know,
who is pushing spending cuts. I think Republicans
put a tax cut in the law before Christmas
this year, then the next year it does open
up the spending cutters on Capitol Hill to
really push more for spending cuts. I'll give
you an example of that. The House Freedom
Caucus now, the most conservative members
in the House, they're holding their fire now
on spending cuts because they want the tax
cut to go through first. The tax cut goes
through, sign in the law, I think it's going
to really open up the scenarios for spending
cuts.
To make meaningful spending cuts, you got
to go where the money is, and that really
means old age entitlements, Medicare, and
social security, and defense spending. None
of those seem to be anything that Republicans
are known for even pretending that they want
to cut. Will those be on the table, assuming
tax reform goes through?
To Trump's credit, he actually does go after
some of the entitlement. Social security disability
insurance is an 150 dollar billion program.
It is a giant spending program and it's hugely
wasteful. What it does is, it has encouraged
millions of Americans who only have marginal
disabilities, who should be in the workforce,
it's kept them out of the workforce even though
really, they should be in the workforce, a
lot of them want to work, but if you take
any disability money, you essentially can't
work. It's a crazy system. Trump has proposed
reforms on that system, to his credit. That
is the type of reform that I think could move
ahead next year.
We'll leave it there. Thank you so much.
Thanks a lot, Nick.
We've been talking with Chris Edwards. He's
the Director of Tax Policy at the Cato Institute,
and he's looking forward to tax reform and
spending reform.
Absolutely.
For Reason, I'm Nick Gillespie.